hey it's Alex here and welcome to this
video on transponder key programming so
what I'm going to do is give you a quick
overview about what we're going to learn
in this lesson and then at the end of
this lesson you're also going to see a
live demonstration of me programming a
car key so let's get into it so what
we're going to cover are what are
transponder Keys how a mobilizer systems
work and the process of cloning and
programming transponder key
so let's get into it so what are
transponder keys so in basic terms a
transponder key is a car key that
contains a small microchip inside that
microchip communicates with the car's
immobilizer system and allows the engine
to start so here's how that works when
the key is IGN inserted into the
ignition that chip in the in the key the
micr chip the transponder sends a signal
to the ECU usually an RD signal radio
signal if that code matches the car
starts now if the code doesn't match the
car won't start so even if the key
physically fits even if it turns the
lock it will not start the car now
obviously this is this was invented to
prevent people stealing cars that's the
main use of this so that's just
something simple to understand at this
stage um so for an example a 2005 Ford
Focus uses a transponder key while a
1995 Toyota Corolla does not so with the
Toyota Corolla you'd be able to actually
cut a key to it um if you had the
original key you could simply duplicate
that key turn the ignition and drive
away whereas with a 2005 Ford Focus even
if you cut the key to it correctly it
wouldn't start the engine you would need
this transponder in the key to make it
start so the different types of
transponders are fixed code transponders
so these us a single code for all keys
rolling Co code or often called crypto
uh transponders generate a new code
every time the key is used so this is
obviously an extra layer of security so
literally every time the the key is used
it will write itself a new code and then
you've got a encrypted trans trans
bonders which are more advanced and
harder to clone so some common Brands so
Ford Toyota and Honda use these rolling
code crypto transponders BMW and
Mercedes for example use the high
security encrypted
transponders now a quick tip is the type
of transponder key determines whether it
can be cloned or programmed into the ECU
so you might have circumstances where a
customer might come to you you ask for a
duplicate key it's not as
straightforward just to uh duplicate
that key you would need to program a new
key into the vehicle and then program
the existing key as well so you just got
to keep that in mind it really depends
on the make and model so how do these
immobilizer systems work then so what is
an immobilizer so it's an anti- theft
system that prevents the car from
starting without the program key it
works by verifying the chip signal from
the key before allowing ignition and the
key components of this are the
transponder key itself so this is the
physical key with the transponder inside
the chip inside the antenna ring so this
is the often known as the reader coil
this is what goes around the uh actual
ignition
itself and that reads the signal from
the key and then you've got the ECU
which is essentially like the the car's
brain so this is where it stores
programmed key codes and many other
things for the vehicle um so that's like
the if you think of that as like the
brain to the vehicle so here's an
example so if a thief cuts a new metal
key for a car but doesn't have it
programmed um with the transponder the
immobilizer will prevent the engine from
starting now if you did program the
correct transponder to the vehicle
you could then start the car so how to
use a key programmer to to clone keys so
what is key cloning so key cloning is
copying the transponder chip data onto a
blank
transponder so any simple example a
customer comes to you with a working key
you're able to read that that chips data
using your machine and then transfer
that data onto a blank chip onto a new
chip so this works best for fix code
transponders so the steps to that don't
worry I'm going to get into a visual
demonstration of this but just to give
you an outline you would insert the
original key into the programmer read
and copy the chip data then insert the
new blank transponder key write the copy
data onto that new key and test to make
sure the key
starts now common Key Programs for we
have covered that in another lesson so
if you haven't got the full course for
this uh there's a link in the
description where you can get this
entire course for free um so that would
be an ex xhorse an utel or smart key
programmer and one thing to keep in mind
is not all transponders can be cloned
now some require ECU programming instead
um so another thing to to keep in mind
here is um when it comes to these fixed
codes transponders you you might think
that your business if you're just
starting in this business now you might
think that the common house uh the
common High Street Key Cutters are
competing with you because well can't
they just copy any key and uh go ahead
well the truth is they can't because the
when it comes to these crypto
transponders with the rolling data
they're not going to be able to do most
of them because they're going to need to
actually physically leave their shop and
pro um plug the machine the the key
programmer into the vehicle and do it
that way they' need to program a key
from scratch and not many High Street
shops offer that also if the customers
lost all the keys to their vehicle most
of these High Street Key Cutters don't
physically have the staff or the
capability of leaving the shop going out
on site picking and decoding in the car
uh cutting the key and so on so you need
to think that you're not in danger by
these key cutting shops and often they
will call you if you go around some of
these key cutting shops hand them your
business card they will actually send
you plenty of work uh which they can't
dosel so let's talk about adding keys so
this is instead of cloning uh this will
be when a new key is registered directly
into the ECU so this is is required for
Rolling code and encrypted transponders
and often when an original key isn't
present so the steps of doing this is
you would connect your key programmer to
the car's o OBD Port now we're going to
get into this in
another shortly you're going to get a
visual demonstration of this but the obb
port is essentially just a socket in the
car that's usually hidden in the
footwell area where you plug your key
programming machine into and that would
allow you to talk directly to the ECU um
rather than using radio signals so you
would select the cars make model and
year you would enter the pin or security
code if required it's not always
required then you would insert the new
key with obviously the correct
transponder in and follow the onscreen
programming steps and then you would
obviously test the key to make sure it
starts so as you can see this is really
just pushing buttons so if you can
operate an iPhone or you know a simple
laptop you can do this because it's
really we're not talking about any Dex
dextrous skill here there's no uh you
don't need to train for years to be able
to to learn how to just follow the
onscreen programming steps you just need
to be able to know um obviously the
correct parts to use and then to be able
to follow follow these instructions that
the machine's going to give you so some
common key programmers are an utel smart
Pro and the key tool plus um and an
example might be a 2012 Honda Accord
requires ECU programming while a 2004
Fiesta can be cloned so let's say a
customer comes to you with a 2012 Honda
Accord um and you'll you can't just
simply duplicate their key um whereas
with a for 2000 uh Ford Fiesta you'll be
able to just simply clone the key uh
clone the
transponder so here's some issues and
solutions so what happens if a car won't
start after programming usually you need
to check if the ecu's accepted the key
ensure that the key is correctly uh
coded verify that the transponder chip
is compatible so one of the main
mistakes people make is is trying to try
trying to program the wrong chip to the
vehicle so you need to make sure uh you
can double check to make sure you're
using the correct transponder now the
key programmer can't communicate with
the ECU so you need to check if your if
this car requires a security pin code
now most of the time your key programmer
will be able to read the PIN code the
security pin code for the vehicle or the
customer customer will actually have
this pin code without even knowing it so
usually it's actually in the car in the
glove box in their uh log book for the
vehicle you can often find the PIN code
in there and you can also call the
dealership where the cars purchased from
and retrieve the PIN code from there but
usually your key programming machine
will actually read the PIN code itself
uh so make sure you're you're putting in
the correct PIN code make sure the OBD
sockets working and make sure you also
have a a battery tester plugged in as
well battery booster because that will
also um improve the communication
between the key programmer and the
ECU so what happens if your duplicate
key doesn't work after you've programmed
it sometimes it might say that it's
programmed successfully but it still
doesn't work now just obviously ensure
the chip was cloned correctly by going
through the procedure again or you can
try manually adding that key to the ECU
rather than cloning it okay so you might
try and clone a key it doesn't work you
can then try and add it manually so a
good tip is to always have multiple key
programming tools uh to make sure you've
got good coverage but don't start off
like that purchase the most basic key
programmer you can find and get your
feet wet first get confident using it
and then eventually when the market
demands it you'll know when the right
time to purchase more equipment so now I
invite you to watch a key cutting
demonstration so what I want you to do
when you watch this um in this
demonstration is to observe how the
original key is read so we're going to
talk about a key dup uh key duplication
here identify the programming process so
how straightforward it is just push in
the buttons and take notes on the steps
and tool used so your goal for this
lesson really is to understand the full
process before attempting key
programming on an actual vehicle so
let's check the video out and you're
just going to select the
vehicle the make is a
Ford which is
European and the model is a
Transit go to Transit and we know it's
the
2012 so we go between 2007 to
2013 select that we know it's bladed now
it's just going to literally tell us
what to do switch ignition on and press
enter now you want to be looking at the
dash lights in this moment the moment
you can see we got a red flashing light
there so back to this press enter
this is just going to find the vehicle
so it's found it press
enter and now special
functions you can see the radio's come
on
already and we want to go to add key
little says one token will be used
that's fine is this you is this
something to do with you now it's just
doing its
thing Keys program free now it's saying
press back to exit or end to program
next key that's it and back to exit
procedure complete press
enter now if we look at the dash
now we'll see that it's flashing
slowly okay so if we just turn that
off we'll turn off the
ignition always unplug the ODB before
you test it that's just a little thing I
like to do I don't know if makes a
difference but I prefer to do that um if
we turn the ignition on now you see the
red light comes on but it's gone off so
that's a good sign if we just turn the
ignition now make sure it's out of
gear there we go we have lift off give
it a few revs to charge the
battery and there we go okay so I hope
you enjoyed that demonstration there so
here's a quick summary of this lesson so
transponder keys are used uh as
chip-based security to prevent theft
immobilized systems require a part
programmed key to start the engine key
cloning works for fixed code
transponders when an original keys
present while rolling codes require ECU
programming using key programmers
locksmith can add the Del and reprogram
keys so what I want you to do if you
want to get the full course of this is
called autol locksmith Mastery there's a
link in the description of this video
down in the description box or in the
comments area you can get this course
for it's 100% free all you need to do is
set up your account and you get the free
course also subscribe to the channel
because we're also going to be talking
about lockpicking and entry techniques
so I look forward to seeing you there